the mushrooms said and i'm sure you'll
be horrified
the mushrooms said to me in the amazon
when they were revealing
all this information and and deputizing
us to do
all these things and we said why us
why should we be you know the ambassador
of an alien species into human culture
and they said because you have never
believed
anybody because you have never
uh given over uh
your belief to anyone
uh in 1971 i was 23
my brother was 19. i'd spent several
years
in asia already having been run out of
berkeley
because of the revolution and
we were
graduates of the lsd revolution but it
had left us
wanting more specifically wanting
the kinds of experiences that the
classical
commentators on psychedelics described
and by that i mean
people like have locked ellis in the
dance of life
or s weir mitchell
who wrote about masculine we lsd
for us never delivered
visions it delivered insight
and feelings and complex thoughts but
not visions not activity in the visual
cortex that these classical commentators
had led us to expect and i
had been in india for a number of years
and pretty well managed to convince
myself
that whatever spirituality had ever been
there it had evaporated
thousands of years ago and that what we
were left with was a very
grasping and mendacious priestly
hierarchy that was about as cynical as
religion gets
and i was raised catholic so i know what
i'm talking about
[Music]
and uh so then we decided well where the
gnosis must be
is in the amazon where we knew there was
a pristine
aboriginal shamanism based on
palestinians
[Music]
and i stress our youth because
i think people imagine that you can only
make contributions
if you're old and laden with degrees
and that sort of thing and basically our
our pure reckless inventiveness
carried us further into the heart of the
mystery than i would
ever have believed possible and
i should say a little bit about the
method because i think it's important
rationalism in confrontation
with the weird edges is what's always
worked for me
in other words if you're a true believer
if you have some pre-packaged philosophy
then you're going to miss a great deal
because you're
pre-programmed to ignore what doesn't
fit into your
model and it doesn't matter what your
model is
but if you are simply the open-minded
skeptic slash witness
and then if you push at the edges
of the phenomenal world you know go
to the highest mountains the oldest
cities the deepest deserts the most
remote jungles and just simply put
yourself
in these circumstances the cosmic giggle
can get at you you know it can't get at
you if you're
pursuing your job delivering messages
for matthew and son
or whatever it is you've got going but
if you will
tear the human atom of your
individuality
out of the collectivity and set yourself
into a wilderness a desert an
uninhabited island
then this thing can rise
out of the depths and communicate at the
chooses
shape your life for sure blow your mind
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in early february of 1971
i was passing through southern colombia
on my way with my brother and friends to
an expedition
into colombian amazona our route led us
through florencia
the provincial capital of the department
of kakita
there we paused a few days awaiting an
airplane to carry us to our embarkation
point on the rio kutamaio
a river whose vast expanse is the border
between colombia
and her two southern neighbors ecuador
and peru
the day was especially hot and we had
left the oppressive confines of our
hotel
near the noisy central market and bus
station
we walked southwest out of town perhaps
a mile
here with the warm waters of the rioja
across
rolling pastures of tall grass
after swimming in the river playing in
deep pools the warm torrent had carved
in the black basaltic stream bed
we returned through the same meadows
one more familiar than i with the
appearance of stropharia cubensis
pointed out a single large specimen
standing tall and alone in an old bit of
cow manure
impulsively and at my companion
suggestion i ate the whole mushroom
it all occupied but a moment and then on
we trudged
tired from our swim a tropical
thunderstorm
moving toward us along the eastern edge
of the andean cordiera
where florencia is located
for perhaps a quarter hour we walked on
mostly in silence
wearily i hung my head almost hypnotized
by the sight of the regular motion of my
boots
cutting through the grass to align my
back to throw off my lethargy i paused
and stretched
scanning the horizon the feeling of the
bigness of the sky that i have come to
associate with psilocybin
rushed down on me there for the first
time
i asked my friends to pause and sat down
heavily on the ground
a silent thunder seemed to shake the air
before me
things stood out with a new presence and
significance
it came like a wave and passed like a
wave
as the first fury of the tropical storm
burst over us leaving us soaked
in this sodding retreat brief moment
receding and granted withdrawal
and unmentioned by me i recognized my
experience
as being induced by the mushroom but i
was involved i thought
in a deep jungle search for
hallucinogens of a different sort
orally active dmt containing drugs and
yahay and its bad mixture plants
i filed the mushroom experience as
something to look into another time
long time residents of colombia assured
me that the mushroom occurred
exclusively on the dung of
cebu cattle and i assumed that in the
jungle of the interior where i was
shortly to be i could expect no cattle
or pasture i put the thought of
mushrooms from my mind as i anticipated
the rigors of the rio putamaya descent
toward our target destination a remote
mission called loch herrera
we'll just start with a song that was uh
inspired by
some experiences that terence speak
[Music]
we can spots to distant galaxies
without any rocket ship we can ride the
racing and neural
purpose of the bridge
[Music]
[Music]
a bit like you're going insane yeah
yeah inner and outer space
[Music]
[Music]
outer
[Music]
[Music]
to feel space a bit like you're going
insane
[Music]
[Music]
we can be fantastic conspiracies
about all the evil in the world
the theorize that conceptualizes any
[Music]
baggage
inner and outer space are exactly the
same
[Music]
inner and outer space are exactly the
same
at dawn the appointed morning all are
animals
cameras itching butterfly nets plant
presses formaldehyde
notebooks finnegan's weight all the
things that one must have
to go into the amazon were piled at the
river's edge
on the tiny plating boat that was to be
our vessel
hermito our captain
indicated that we were to have the area
on top of the cases of father
flores soda we were informed that it was
six to twelve days to where we wanted to
go
depending on business puerto le guisamo
disappeared
and the river the green bank the shrill
of
insects and parrots the brown water
became our world
[Music]
mm-hmm
[Music]
out on the river the past could enter
the stillness and exfoliate
before the mind's eye like some dark
rose of interlocking kazoo
forces visible and hidden stretching
back into one's past
migrations religious conversions
discoveries
make each a microcosm of the larger
pattern of history on a scale of
millennia
the inertia of introspection is toward
memory
for only in memory is the past
recaptured and understood
in the fact of experiencing and making
the present we are all actors
but in the lacuna in the rare moments
when experience in the present is a
minimal thing
an indoor and self-examining thing
then memory is free to speak
and called forth the landscapes of our
striving
in other moments now past
now the now that is a time beyond the
confines of this story
and now in which this story is past i do
not worry the past as i did then
it is now set for me in a way that it
was not set then
not set then because so recent
still to be relived in memory and
learned from
five days of river travel lay before us
undemanding freeing the mind to rove and
scan
[Music]
two all-inclusive categories emerged in
the world that was our vessel and crew
and ourselves out on a broad river this
distant
banks were no more than a dark green
line separating river and sky
two categories the familiar and the
unfamiliar
the unfamiliar was everywhere drawing
inane analogies into common conversation
the putamayo is like the ganges the
jungle invokes
ambone the sky is similar to the skies
of the serengeti plain
etc the illusion of understanding
a lame way of getting one's bearings the
unfamiliar does not give up its secrets
in this game
the putimayo does not become like the
ganges
the unfamiliar must become known as
itself
before it is correctly recognized the
familiar things are
people the people here appear as known
quantities because they have been known
in the past
so long as the future remains like the
past
they will remain known quantities
certainly this is not new york
boulder or berkeley but we are trying to
become extra environmentals
develop a sense of appropriate action
that is never at a loss
it is the familiarity of these people
that makes them
windows in my imagination opening
onto the past
why had people like ourselves come to
the steaming jungles of amazonian
colombia
we were a party of five bound by
friendship extravagant imagination
naivete and a dedication to travel and
exotic experience
ev our translator was the only member of
the group
not long an acquaintance of us all she
was an american like ourselves who had
lived several years in south america
and had traveled in the east where i had
passed her once in the kathmandu airport
another story in colombia she
was recently free of a long relationship
and
fell in with our group having nothing
better to do
she and i were lovers of some two weeks
when we arrived at la torreira
the other three members of our party
beside myself
were my brother the youngest and least
traveled of us
a student of botany and a colleague of
long-standing
vanessa an old-school friend of mine
from the experimental college in
berkeley
trained in anthropology and photography
and traveling on her own
and dave another old friend of mine a
gay meditator
a maker of pottery an embroiderer of
blue jeans
and like vanessa a new yorker
as for myself just four months before
this trip my brother and i had endured
the grief of the death of our mother
previous to that i had been traveling
three years
in india and indonesia had worked in
japan and then in canada where we had
all held a reunion and planned this
amazon expedition to investigate the
depths of the psychedelic experience
i deliberately do not wish to say much
about any of us
let me say though that we were
miseducated perhaps
but well educated certainly
our differences arose out of the faith
that each had in his own ability to
understand
the situation correctly often these
descriptions did not agree
as is a common enough situation among
strong personalities
or witnesses to an unusual event
we were complex people or we would not
have been doing what we were doing
none of us were yet 24 years old
we had been drawn together through the
political turmoil that had characterized
years
shared in berkeley we had sorted the
ideological options
and had decided to put all of our chips
on the exploration of the potential of
the psychedelic experience
as the shortest path to the sort of
millennium that our radical politics
had taught us to hope for
when we went to la cherrera which is the
the epicenter of the witoto
tribe it's their ancestral home so
that's where we
had to go to get this ukuhay
this orally active varola paste or so we
thought
so we went to la cherera in search of
that and when we got to la cherrera
uh you know we've been warned by a
couple anthropologists we've met along
the way and so on that you know you just
can't
march into this village and start asking
about ukuhei they're going to go
completely nuts and they'll probably
kill you because it's a big secret
you know so he said yeah yeah yeah we
know but we're going anyway and
but we'll be careful you know so we got
there
and when we got to la cherrera it turns
out la chere is this mission
village in the middle of the amazon that
had been cleared
for cattle and so
you know there were cattle all over the
place and that the
cow dung of the cebu cow is the
preferred substrate for the
salicy kubensus mushrooms so at this
at this place literally there were huge
clusters of mushrooms growing up out of
every cow pie in the pasture you know
and we knew what they were
we had books and we knew what they were
you couldn't walk through the pasture
without
kicking these things over so i thought
well this is
great you know i mean we were we were
all happy hippies and we thought well
while we're looking for the real mystery
you know here's a nice
distraction you know uh that we can take
and
have fun and giggle and all that and and
so we
said well fantastic and and so
we started nibbling on these things and
it finally got to a point where we were
nibbling on them
quite a lot and because actually
there wasn't that much to eat you know
what we were while we were what we had
brought with us was canned
you know tins of meat and rice and
things like that and so
you know there wasn't a lot to eat and
uh we were actually
you know i mean we put mushrooms in our
soup and in our rice
and we were we were taking them all the
time really
and it led to
a kind of a state of being you know
half loaded on psilocybin all the time
and and we were smoking a lot of pot and
we were
you know a bunch of very sort of verbal
people anyway
and so the conversations and the ideas
just flowed you know and got
stranger and stranger and stranger
one of the things we've noticed on
the mushrooms especially and also on dmt
but on the mushrooms was that
at high doses you could perceive a
sound inside your head like
a buzzing or a sort of like wind chimes
or sort of
you know hard to put your finger on but
that if you listen very closely you
could
sing you could imitate it and
at a certain point your and your
imitation wasn't that close to what it
actually sounded like but at a certain
point
they locked in to each other and then
this sound which was kind of like a
howling
and kind of like a buzzing and kind of
like
screaming and it kind of you know
like singing it was all these things i
mean i could make it right here but i'm
not going to
because i don't want to disrupt the
fabric of space time
but but it was like that and it would
it would uh it would elicit
you know long intervals of hallucination
and you know it was just very satisfying
that you could modulate
sound in this way and get this extended
effect and so we came up with this idea
that well maybe
this we can use sound as
the force to
to catalyze what was essentially a
chemical reaction
you know which we speculated
that uh you know if you hit
the molecules of a mushroom with the
right frequency that you could cause
psilocybin to
intercalate into the dna of the mushroom
simultaneously with the dna of our own
brains and it would achieve a
superconducting
state and it would generate a standing
waveform
which would essentially be the standing
wave or a hologram right that's what a
standing
that's what a hologram is it's a
standing waveform
that would reflect all of the
information
in dna you know in a
form that you could look at and examine
you know that was our idea um
and of course it was it was uh it was a
crazy idea
and had no possibility of being
you know realized at all but we had so
talked ourselves into
uh we were so totally convinced that we
were on the right track
and we were so ripped on psilocybin all
the time
that we actually talked ourselves in we
conceived this experiment and
utterly believed that it was going to
work
and so strongly did we believe it was
going to work
that when all these strange things
started to happen in the environment we
said well of course this is feed
this is a shock wave coming back from
the future
and what this shows is that you know
eight hours
24 hours up ahead we've succeeded
and the fact that things are getting
weird
proves that we've succeeded up
in the future you know and so we got
ourselves into this like cognitive
sort of cul-de-sac where something had
to happen
well you know so when we actually
performed the experiment we knew it was
going to succeed
and when we made the sound and directed
it at the mushroom and all that what we
postulated was going to happen
didn't happen of course how could it
you know but something had to happen and
so what happened
was that we went on this simultaneous
trip uh i mean now we're beyond drugs
and into
psychosis basically but where i became
you know completely spread across the
universe that was my perception that i
had
taken dmt and i
recollected this that i i recollected
back to an occasion
when i had smoked emt and had the
feeling that i
my ego my consciousness had been
completely spread across
the entire space-time continuum
and so that's what i thought had
happened and
and terence was having this simultaneous
uh complementary psychosis
where he became more or less totally
focused on the environment
and totally focused on me because i
think
a lot of it was concerned that oh my god
you know you finally did it you finally
drove your little brother crazy
you know and it was true and so then he
was all
you know protective and all that and and
he
became very focused on me and on getting
me back in the meantime i'm
cruising you know uh all of space time
and
slowly over days about two weeks
every 24 hours i went through a process
of reintegration
you know where every 24 hours i became a
little less literally spaced
i mean it was it was and because we were
working inside this alchemical metaphor
and the idea of the stages of this
process
and because all of our companions there
were although they were
you know probably as loose as we were
but they were out of the loop at this
point i mean they were just appalled
you know they basically wanted to call
in the airplanes
and get us to a mental hospital and get
the thorazine
as quickly as possible but terence and i
both we understood each other we knew
what was going on we could communicate
and terence was holding them off and
saying no no
just let this process go
and i'm very grateful to him that he did
because
i i think i think that's exactly what
needed to happen
it was a re it was an
integration process which if it had been
interrupted i probably never would have
recovered
but because we let it go its natural
course
uh you know i came back together
more or less utterly transformed
not necessarily in a better way but at
least you know i can put my shoes on and
tie them and stuff like that and
[Music]
chapter 11 the experiment at
la cherrera the night was absolutely
black
a low-lying cloud bank had appeared
muffling the small world of la
cherera and wrapping it in a bowl of
all-absorbing velvet darkness
following the storm we had rebuilt our
fire and had driven off
several liters of water from our
infusion of banisteriopsis cappy
while i completed the boiling ev and
dennis went to their hammocks and lay
down to await the completion of the
preparations
we laughed together and talked softly
yet in spite of this there was an
undercurrent of tension
as we approached the experiment into
which so much of our energy had been
poured it was very critical
they were becoming very clumsy and seem
to find their bodies hard to handle
it was that which had sent them to their
hammocks
i said that i would do whatever needed
attention
our little hut on it stilts looked in
the flickering
fire light like a small spaceship
dropped into the howling jungles of an
alien world
we all felt like we were approaching
hyper spatial overdrive
there was a sense of immense energies
accumulating
the effect was reinforced by the
hammocks hanging like
acceleration slings ready to receive a
starship's crew
dennis lay in his hammock nearly unable
to hold a pencil but writing furiously
in tight operational terms
about the experiment just ahead
dennis explained that he was unable to
move very well because something having
to do with the backward flow of time
and the ever increasing constraints on
the set of possible futures
had rendered him nearly immobile only
the mind
planning and computing was free
i finished boiling the yahei i ground
the admixture plants and added them to
the cooling brew
i moved the yahei into the hut then the
mushroom
those things in place we were ready to
begin
prior to this point we had taken no
hallucinogens for several days
the effects we were experiencing were
not arising from that source
something else was happening
dennis was now narrating our countdown
toward an omega point
that none of us could really understand
we were completely transformed
with the expectation that possibly we
would witness the outbreak of the
millennium
it was dennis who finally spoke a series
of quantized energy levels have to be
broken through in order to bond this
thing
it is part mythology part psychology
part applied physics who knows we will
make three attempts
before we break out of the experimental
mode
we all drank the yahei sending it
churning through our guts
dennis took only one mushroom so that he
could hear the tone
darkness was utter and we had no clocks
[Music]
all was finally in readiness the living
mushroom
the harming brew the harmine smoking
mixture
after we each had taken a half a cup of
the yahei infusion
we settled down to wait dennis had been
hearing the esr
tone that he deemed the cena quan non of
what we were attempting
for the past several days after about 15
minutes he announced that he could hear
it more clearly
and that it was gaining strength he felt
prepared to attempt the experiment at
any time he said
the candle went out and he sounded his
first howl of hypercarbilation
it was mechanical and loud like a bull
roarer and
ended with a convulsive spasm that
traveled throughout his body and landed
him out of his hammock on
[Music]
we re-lit the candle only long enough to
determine that everyone wanted to
continue
again a long whirring yodel strange and
unexpectedly mechanical each time it was
sounded
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i suggested a break before the third
attempt but dennis was quite agitated
and eager to
bring it through as he put it we settled
in for the third yell and when it came
it was like the others but lasted much
longer and became
much louder it was like an electric
siren
wailing atomic attack over the still
night jungle
[Music]
so
one must take enough psilocybin to allow
the sound to be audible
this sound we understand to be the esr
of the resonating psilocybin alkaloids
within the mushroom
the presence of rapidly metabolizing
high-energy tryptamines within the yahay
acts as antenna that sensitizes the
neural matrix to the spin resonance
energy
of the stefarius psilocybin it is this
principle that allows the signal to be
made audible
it must then be amplified by the
tryptomine admixture antennas
do what is
[Applause]
absolute darkness of our amazon hut was
silence
the silence of the transition from one
world to another
the silence of the kidney ago gap
parents described me about he said
dennis is totally broken through and he
made a sound
and i said uh i don't exactly understand
what you want
and he says well a lot of people don't
see it
and it's best that they don't but
there's
uh insect like anthropologists studying
this
and at the time of making the sound
you're hearing the sound
this scene or unseen guardian
well i think she said
operate on your mouth so you can make
the sounds
there are insect anthropologists
studying the human race yes
and it's about i think he said 12 to 15
feet tall
well anyway what happened to dennis was
he was uh
just out there taking up his but of
course it was after at least a week of
mushrooms
and uh he was taking this
and a light came out of the ground
and it just began to rumble up from
inside him
and he layered out the sound and after
that
changed it was just like terror before
[Music]
they're both very tall and skinny maybe
that uh
dennis was taller and he just looked
down at me you know
with this blueish haze around his face
and his
eyes were so wide open
like this looking right into me saying
michael i know you'll make the sound
but we'll ceremony
people who have never taken
hallucinogenic drugs but have
some mild interest in it or just in the
course of generally educating yourself
about reality
i think people who have never taken
psychedelics think that it's
sort of like dreaming while you're awake
or
geometric patterns colors they always
say
the colors the colors malarkey the
colors forget the colors
it is not like that psychedelic
experiences
at effective doses not
piddling doses effective doses are
visionary scenarios they are
three-dimensional unfoldments of
information that is extraordinarily
complex
archetectonically connected and ordered
that's not what i want to talk about i
want to talk about what is unique to
psilocybin
what is unique to psilocybin is that
overlaid over what i just described
is big surprise a voice
a voice everybody knows this
who has to do with this stuff gordon
watson
richard schulte's albert hoffman the
giants
know that this stuff is animated
this is not a drug it's something which
is disguising
itself as a drug in order not
to spread alarm there is a voice
which speaks to you in the language of
your homeland
whether that be mazateken or english
and the voice surprises you
in other words you cannot anticipate it
now of course at this point
though i don't imagine many of them have
forced their way in here
the psychological school will come
forward and say well it's a voice
typical of mental aberration
symptom one of schizophrenia a voice
yes yes we are not naive we read
we went to the same schools you did
thank you if
we are in fact being penetrated by a
non-human intelligence
that presumably somehow
perhaps not physically but perhaps
physically
can cross from star to star
then we are dealing with something
vastly more sophisticated than ourselves
that's just given that the get-go
well if it's vastly more advanced than
we are
then dna sequencing a
complete understanding of the molecular
genesis
of thought so forth and so on would be
no problem for that level of technical
sophistication
you would also like to think that ethics
and good taste would it keep pace
with this evolutionary process so to my
mind
the idea of fleets of alien spacecraft
filling the skies of earth
that's as unsubtle as kicking down
somebody's front door with an m1
tank to announce we're here
i don't think you would do it that way
if you really wanted
to study a
aboriginal race and you really
had a hot technology what you would do
is you would study their social
psychology
and you would say are there any chinks
in the armor of their expectations about
how reality behaves
and you would discover in studying us
this species intoxicates itself
and it has a curious attitude towards
its intoxications
anything goes so
if somebody drinks a pint of stolochenia
and announces that they see pink
elephants
we are all amused of course you do you
were drunk out of your mind
isn't it obvious that an alien would
hide its presence
in an intoxication that this
is the non-invasive tasteful
respectful way
to have intercourse with another species
i was very interested in coming to
this thing and studying the psychology
of the group and
it was very fascinating to me that
both of the speakers where i listened to
the whole thing
were very concerned to refute the
psychological
explanation which i gather is the
antichrist around here
and as i understand it somebody said to
me the first thing they said to me i
thought
my god these people are on and he said i
want you to know that this jungian thing
is [ __ ]
he said okay that's fine
however this is like
beating a dead horse has the news from
quantum physics not reached the ufo
community is it not now thoroughly
assimilated that an observer is
necessary for reality to exist at all
it's all psychological
there's no distinction and so these
people who have such enthusiasm
for beryllium ships from arcturus or
wherever
should be informed you know same same
so now what is physics telling us saying
uh folks hold
your horses here it turns out the
cheerful
world of uh billiard ball
like atoms winging their way
through newtonian space is in for
serious revision it turns out that these
particles aren't even
particles they're waves well no
not exactly they're both well what i
actually meant to say
was and you discover the babble of
mad people is what is coming out of the
physics departments
today science has collapsed its
core has given way to contradiction
carried far enough the analysis of this
stage
will show you that it has no quote
reality to it now this plays nicely
right into my hands let's go back now to
those drug-induced hallucinations
you know i think every every ufo
investigator in the country
they have these forms when they come
rushing out to your house when you
report it 11 mile long green cigars
overhead and the first question is
are you intoxicated did you have a
history of taking drugs what is your
relationship to altered states
most encounters with extraterrestrials
take place
in altered states that's what altered
states are
reality is you know the tip of an
iceberg
of irrationality that we've managed to
drag
ourselves up onto for a few panting
moments
before we slip back into the sea of the
unreal
[Music]
dave and vanessa followed me back to the
forest
grumbling a good part of the way
when we had gone slightly past the place
where i had parted from dennis
we came upon something which could not
at first be fitted into any set of
expectations
this was dennis ruana and shirt
discarded in the middle of the path
next came a pair of pants and then
further on two sweat socks
and though i was to learn this only
later
his glasses and his boots had also been
hurled away
following this trail of cast off
garments led us back to the hut in the
forest
there we found evan dennis both naked
and sitting on the floor of the hut
discussing
and doing the ask dennis meditation
with the comment that you cannot receive
a proper initiation unless you are naked
dennis insisted that we take off our
clothes
vanessa peeled and dave and i followed
her example
the presence of the mushroom was there
and it seemed to be saying
take off your clothes throw everything
away
everything is breaking all objects are
no good to you now
throw everything away you do not need it
anymore
we all looked at each other glossy pubic
hair and secret genitals now in the
sunshine
i rolled a joint then we sat in a circle
and smoked
we told dave and vanessa about the
teaching and urged them to try it with
varying degrees of success
since a voice in the head is a very
subjective thing
if one has it there is no doubt if one
does not have it it seems a very
murky thing everything was very amicable
except that dennis was showing a
tendency to talk right
through other people's comments as if
they were not
present it was as though he were on a
different
time track from the rest of us since we
really seemed unable to realize that
someone else was talking
we thought that it was logical to untie
our hammocks from the house
and take nothing but our hammocks and go
naked into the jungle
tie the hammocks in a tree and then get
into these handlings
we would then explore the mode because
clearly you could do more than ask or
answer questions
the door was standing open god alone
knew what one could do i asked the thing
in my mind what should be done and had
received
instruction that we should visually
meditate on our lives
and starting from the present trace back
to our entire life
encountering and setting things right
with every sentient creature that we had
ever wronged
when we reached the end of this process
we would leave our bodies and be somehow
free in the dimension of absolute
freedom that seemed so near
lying in our hammocks we set out to
meditate our way to hyperspace
i could see myself at la cherera then
going down the trail to ellen canto
up the river to legislate back to bogota
back to canada and at each point i would
meet the people that i had lived my life
with
and i would say we got it i'm sorry i
hope i didn't offend you too much back
there in 3d
it's all over now it's all over
i could see people immediately i reached
out for all of them
i seem to be able to reach them we're in
the amazon i explained to each
and now we're going home or someplace
the vision had an utterly bizarre
quality tears welled up behind my closed
eyelids
it was very peculiar the voice of the
teacher spoke
in my head you found it this is it
it's all over now there is no more
within a few hours the superstructure of
human civilization is going to collapse
and your species is going to go to
jupiter and then to the stars
a day of high adventure dawns for man
at last
[Music]
during this sleepless period i sat one
night
on this laundry rock below the police
house where dennis was
incarcerated and he was more or less
incarcerated because he refused to keep
his clothes on and anything put in a
room with him he would
hurl out the window even hurled the
window
frame out the window so he was
thorough
[Laughter]
i said nothing to anyone but i formed
the resolve
not to spend that sleepless night as i
had spent the others
wandering the fields like this fox
spirit or meditating at the choro
rather i would sit here where the lake
emptied and the agar parana resumed its
languid course
here at the boat landing 70 feet down a
steep mud bank from the river house
i would sit through the night and watch
and so all night long i sat reviewing
the things that had passed
seeming to divide my consciousness and
send it both
backward through my family tree and
forward
into the future i seemed to see all the
years ahead
i saw some technique emerging from this
contact
which i now think is the technique for
growing strophary cubensis
our careers pursued across space and
time
and finally vindication as the world
realized the truth of the
trans-dimensional nature of the
stropharia visions
and the true nearness of the worlds that
they had thrown open
for it had become my belief that the
contact with an intelligent and utterly
alien species
was beginning for humanity it seemed
that out of the long
night of cosmic time the novelty of
novelties
the moment of contact between mines on
utterly different planes was beginning
we were among the first to achieve
contact with this
other species it was the real thing
we had come to the equatorial jungle to
explore the dimensions glimpsed in
tryptomine ecstasy
and there in the darkness of the heart
of the amazon
we had been found and touched by this
bizarre
and ancient life form that was now
awakening to the global potential of a
symbiotic relationship with technical
humanity
all night long strange vistas and
insights
poured through me i saw gigantic
machineries and worlds of vegetable and
mechanical
forms on scales inconceivably vast
time agotized and glittering
seem to pour by me like living super
fluids inhabiting dream regions of
terrible pressure and super
cold and i saw the plan
the mighty plan at last
it was an ecstasy an ecstasis that
lasted hours
and placed the seal of completion on all
of my previous
life at the end i felt reborn
but as what i knew not
the mushroom is a transdimensional
doorway which sly
fairies have left slightly ajar for
anyone to enter into
who can find the key and who wishes to
use this power
the power of vision to explore this
peculiar
and naturally occurring psychoactive
complex
we are closing distance with the most
profound event a planetary ecology can
encounter
the emergence of life from the dark
chrysalis of matter
[Music]
i have always had
a relationship to nature which i pretty
much took for granted
but perhaps it was
it was more intense and somewhat unique
than
most people's i grew up
in a small town in colorado i was very
early into
being a rock hound and then a butterfly
collector i had no interest
in stamps or baseball cards or
anything like that it was always natural
objects
and the attraction of tropical
butterflies
was the the exuberant
expanse of color the
affirmation of
path and richness of the universe that
was seen to be thrown out like
a spark by these things and eventually i
pursued it quite far and was for
some time a professional butterfly
collector
in uh tropical indonesia in a
pre-buddhist incarnation and
this search or iridescence
thrown off by nature seen first
in the glint of metallic ore crystals
and and then in the colorful expanse of
butterflies and then
in tropical fish reached a kind of
apotheosis with the discovery
of the psychedelic plant
hallucinogens where suddenly the color
the flash the iridescence was not
two or three-dimensional but it was
multi-dimensional
it was inside one outside one
it was like the ultimate tropical
aquarium
the ultimate butterfly cabinet the
ultimate mineral show
again i was very lucky i read carl jung
very early before the jungians really
got a hold of him and ruined it
and what young is saying
about conceiving your life as a quest
is absolutely true psyche
is some kind of semi-malleable
medium and if you set yourself up as a
loser
if you image yourself as a loser you
will be a loser
and so forth this is not big news but
what's big news
is that if you set yourself your life up
as a quest
you will actually find something
transcendental and unimaginable i mean i
am living proof of this because i set my
life up as a quest for a perverse reason
to prove that there was no mystery
in other words to debunk it to say you
know i will
follow the ancient formula and show
that it's baloney by doing it perfectly
and achieving
nothing
it's the kind of guy i am
however
i mean i've met people who say you know
i'm psychedelic i know exactly what
you're talking about blah blah you say
oh well what's your what's your drug
history and he said well i do get
dma twice say look
you know just because you've had a glass
of cold water doesn't mean
you are now ready to be food editor for
the la luz gastronomique
my friend i mean there's more to it than
that
believe me
mushrooms are my thing i mean that
they enlightened me they straightened me
out
they love me um
but but the way to do mushrooms
is the very first move if you're
interested
in mushrooms is for god's sake
by a scale by
a scale i mean you wouldn't think that
this would be considered such an exotic
suggestion to people who are going
to put their bodies and minds on the
line
because people don't take enough
[Music]
people do not take enough mushrooms
they take pissant amounts and then they
claim
that they're initiates you must take a
measured five dried grams
on an empty stomach measured
and when you see what that is you'll
realize
that you know you weren't even camped in
the atrium you were camped in the
driveway
and mushrooms to my in some ways
i mean dmt is the most terrifying and
astonishing
thing in the universe but it's very hard
to know
what to do with it psilocybin
is your friend it wants to teach
it will take you by the hand and
forgive you and lead you and be
with you and it speaks
this is the amazing thing and you're
hearing this from
you know somebody who graduated from
heidegger and fh
bradley it speaks no other psychedelic
does that in my experience occasionally
a phrase will pop into your head
on another substance that is like a gift
an aphorism
but i mean psilocybin raves
it raves and it has positions
i mean you may not like psilocybin as a
person because it is not
the astonishing thing about the
psilocybin entity
to my mind and i get good confirmation
of this
is it is not very earthly i mean it
wants to
show you machines the size of manhattan
in orbit around alien stars it wants to
talk about
the sweep through of the which happened
before the earth cooled and it you know
has seen the empires of the rule
out at the rim and all the rest of it
and it's very puzzling this cosmic
galactarian
tone because then you switch over to
ayahuasca
which is literally just a twist of the
molecule
just the tiniest tweaking of the
molecule
and suddenly it's about childbirth
rivers the land the feminine
looking inside your body curing diseases
feeling telepathy communication
it could hardly be more different and
yet chemically these things are like
two sides of the same coin
yes first come the dancing mice
the little candies the colored grids and
so forth and so on
but what eventually happens quickly
like 10 minutes later is uh
there is an entity in the trance
in the vision there is a mind
there waiting that speaks good english
and invites you up into its room
what it is is it's a voice in the head
that uh people strove to attain
for a thousand years this was the cena
cuanon of
intellectual accomplishment in the
greco-roman world and the logos
told you the right way to live
and this is sort of what you get with
psilocybin you get a voice
that can confound you with the depth and
brilliance
of its answers this is what you want and
i've had over and over the experience of
showing somebody what five grams is
and they're appalled they say my god you
can't be
serious i mean i would i take a
fifth that much a fourth that much
yeah well that's the problem that's why
you don't have elves in the attic
and bats in the belfry like i do
a lot of people have said you're a
hallucination
not you're obsessed with hallucination
i freely admit it
but i will defend my obsession with
vision i think the world wants to be
seen
i think blake was right that the divine
imagination is something beheld
and for me the visions
are the proof that this is not my mind
and the visions are the proof that this
is not simply
chemical chaos in the nervous system
and when we communicate with each other
and understand each other
we instinctively reach for visual
metaphors
i see what you mean look here fella
uh she painted the picture uh his words
were so
beautiful it means that we really
associate
meaning with seeing something
by this time the fog was impenetrable
and we all retired for the night but not
before ever related
that in the silence before the
appearance of the fog
she had had a hallucination with her
eyes closed
of a strange elf-like creature rolling a
complicated polyhedron along the ground
each facet of this polyhedron scene she
said
like a window onto another place in time
or another world it's the stone
i breathed the lapis philosophorum
glimpsed in the amazonian night
seemingly a great
multi-dimensional jewel in the keeping
of a teluric
dwarf the power of the image was deep
and touching
i seem to feel the hopes of the old
alchemists
the puffers great and small who had
sought the lapis and the cloudy swirling
of their alembics
i had never seen or imagined the mystery
of the stone thus
but in listening to ev's description of
what she had seen
an image formed in my mind that to this
day
remains with me it is the image of the
stone as hyperdimensional jewel
become ufo the human soul becomes
starship
it is the universal panacea at the end
of time
all history the shockwave of this final
unveiling of the potential of the human
psyche these thoughts these reveries
seemed then like the stirring of
something vast
something dimly sensed stretched out
over millions of years
something about the destiny of mankind
and the return of the soul
to its awesome and hidden source what
was happening to us
through it all we were still after the
lens-shaped object
what the teacher told me in the first
few days after the experiment was
you almost got it you didn't quite get
it
or rather it used the metaphor of
condensation
it is condensing it was like a perfect
alchemical metaphor
the stone is everywhere it is here
dennis would say i can see it it's 250
feet away to the left down near the
water hole
hovering above the water
the world seemed filled with a near
bending wonder and power
that assured me that all things were
possible
and that the course of things in the
light of this
were moving in the right direction be
amazed at nothing
you are to receive the kingship of the
father
what complicated this was
i who had been cast in the role of the
skeptic
and the witness had noticed that the
moment
he had forged the joint as he called it
something began to happen for me
something very unusual what it was
was the teaching voice familiar
from psilocybin experiences
but with none of the ambiguity and
difficulty of connection
that i had associated with the
psilocybin experiences instead
it just came on and appeared to be
locked in place there was nothing
but this voice and it was talking at
such a speed
that i would walk these jungle trails
like this uh-huh uh-huh
yes yes yes and it was just
you know at that speed not for minutes
but for months you know
and and what it was concerned to
convey is what i
now call the time wave
i was not an itching scholar i was not a
sinologist i
certainly was not a mathematician but
this
inner prompting would give me no peace
until i proceeded along this line
to its conclusion well
i of course the bewildered recipient of
this information was trying to figure
out
to get ahead of the game and say you
know where is this headed what is this
thing
trying to show me and i decided it must
be that what's happening here is i'm
discovering an ancient
chinese calendar because
you know there are 64 hexagrams and six
lines in each hexagram that gives a
grand total of 384
lines or yao that's an interesting
number
a lunation a lunar cycle is 29
point something days anyway 13 of them
are 383.89
days it's within a decimal fraction
of 384 and i thought
uh-huh i'm sort of like the guy who
decoded stonehenge or something this is
this is an agricultural calendar of 13
lunar cycles and from ancient
china apparently and of course the
obvious objection
from people was
but what a lousy calendar it slips 19
days per year against the sun
it's so it's 19 days more than a solar
year
but i think that there may have been a
reason for that
you see we in the west are static freaks
stability freaks so we have a calendar
that does not
move against the fixed stars
the equinoctial and stasial points only
move
with the precession of the equinoxes
which is this very large cycle that you
can't do anything about
but in an ordinary human life it's
hardly noticeable it only moves one
zodiacal
sign every two thousand years so that
tells you how slowly
it it moves we are stability freaks
but if you had a calendar that precessed
19 days
against the solar year a lunar calendar
then you would have a calendar whose
entire message
was change flux
flow you would be born if you were born
at christmas time
and christmas fell in winter at your
birth
before you saw death at age 60
you would have celebrated christmas in
the springtime
at high summer in early fall in
late fall the entire sliding and
slipping of the cosmic machinery
would teach you a lesson the western
mind doesn't want to learn
which is as heraclitus said
pontetrea all flows
all flows nothing less
so i played with that for a while and
and it was interesting but
i was not given peace by my muse
who said no no this is
terence this is stupid stuff you know
that poem by a.e houseman
anyway there was more to it
and so finally i realized or i was told
treat your wave as though it were the
lowest
unit in a modular hierarchy
that is structured the way the eaching
is structured
okay so that sounds arcane but i'll
explain what it means it's fairly
straightforward
it means take the the wave with the 384
yao
the 64 hexagrams running in two
directions
and by the way there are old sayings in
the iching which say
stuff like the forward running numbers
refer to the past the backward running
numbers refer to the future well in the
eachine as we have it today there are
neither forward nor backward running
numbers there are just
numbers so i have the confidence ah
i'm like a noetic archaeologist with nut
pick and toothbrush
i am reconstructing a crushed
intellectual object which if i can get
it all cleaned off
and going again it will be it's
the original cuckoo clock or ferrari or
whatever
it was bear with me we're almost over
the top here
i took the little wave and i put six of
them in a row
to represent six lines
and then i took the wave and i
magnified it by a power of three so it
was three times bigger than it had been
and i laid two of those over my six
to represent the two trigrams that are
components of each hexagram
and then i took my original wave and i
magnified it by a power of six and i
laid it
over the six little ones
over the two middle sized ones i laid
one big one
representing a hexagram in its unitary
totality well
and i felt a great sense of satisfaction
when this was all done and these had all
been generated from the same point
and now what i had at this point was an
eight and a half foot long
piece of paper graph paper covered with
colored pen strokes and tiny crab
like numbers which i kept rolled in a
bamboo
tube and i would corner people
in dime stores and bus stations
and i would say you know what this is
this is a map of history this is a
picture of time
this is how things happen well it
triggered a lot of
alarm in my immediate circle and
my friends were having the what should
be done
meetings you know which it's always a
bad sign when your friends
hold meetings to decide what should be
done
and finally ralph abraham is a great
friend and mathematician
uh he said to me he said you know what
you have
is an occult object nobody
understands this thing but you and it
may make sense and it may
not make sense but the point is no one
can tell and what you have to do if you
want to be taken
seriously is you have to take this
structure and you have to turn it into
an ordinary mathematical object
so that fellow mathematicians
can participate in this dialogue with
you
well essentially it was like telling a
hot and talk
to fly supersonically or something
i i had no clue i am not a mathematician
i had
no clue and i was sort of hoping ralph
would do it
for me you know that i could con some
smart guy into doing it for me
for me terence is
us a special person because of the
breadth of
his knowledge and the
evidence of a phenomenal integrity
within it
so first of all when we first met uh
terence uh who was um
asking me about mathematics kind of
mathematics that i was interested in
at that time that nobody else had even
heard about and
as our relationship developed i saw that
he had this uh
philosophy of time let's say or maybe
even mathematical model for the
structure
of time that is an odd thing for a
purpose person to be
obsessed with and from this obsession he
had to
learn a great deal about history so in
our process
of try logging we find it very much
enriched by
terence's phenomenal knowledge of
history and
not only that but his special way of
saying it is sort of
uh you're familiar with this here
a bardic skill so that
whatever he says will have
more effect than it actually deserves
[Music]
it's almost as though western science
was fascinated by
energy for 5 000 years we pursued
understanding energy and this process
ends with thermal nuclear explosions in
the deserts of the american southwest
we can light the fire that burns in the
heart of the distant stars we
know how to do that that's what the
western mind achieved
political issues aside the eastern mind
was not interested in energy it was
interested in time
and they spent 5 000 years
deconstructing it
looking at it and you don't use atom
smashers you don't
use enormous physical pressure it's a
different
problem and you bring different tools to
bear
you meditate you look inside yourself
you study the
movement of water around pebbles you
consider the situation you study history
so the general conclusion from these
screens
is that novelty is being
increased and conserved as we move
through time now for instance in this
screen which is
further closure with today we see
uh 562 million years
virtually the entire career of higher
life forms on the planet
eight thousand five hundred years on the
screen
the great proto-egyptian civilizations
summer
er ciao dia are strung out
like pearls along this plunge egypt
culminates that ancient hierarchical
form of dominator society mycenaean
pirates
plunder minoan crete at this point
at this point here we have
the periclean age in athens here we have
the augustinian age in rome
down here we have the roman collapse and
then
the oscillating around a mean in a high
novelty domain that has characterized
time
since the fall of the roman empire the
dark ages
is here the 10th century islam
is here the
black death the discovery of america
the european enlightenment world war
ii adolf hitler becomes chancellor of
germany
the atom bomb is dropped on hiroshima
the summer of love is up here
then the reagan era stretches down
through here
and the moment that we're currently
living through
is right down in here
right there here we are
right there right right there
this is this bump we were looking at
then there's a descent into novelty that
reaches
maximum on the 8th of july
and then there's this very steep and
prolonged
period of habituation now if we
look at the past
see how these numbers have now changed
now
today is seen to be
roughly in residence with 745 a.d
the french revolution is down here going
here this is the franco-prussian war in
the american
civil war the 20th century
begins right there and all
and hitler becomes chancellor of germany
right there
uh the moon landing is right there
and then everything we've been living
through has followed on
since then it means that you know any
moment
is a kind of interference pattern
created
by the moments in the past many
moments in the past i mean like this
shows you one
thing this is why it's like
synchronicities in a sense
except that it explains them a different
way it replaces all that mumbo jumbo
about
synchronicity just by saying you know
this is just the inner penetration
so on the way here we passed the
restaurant called maya palinka
yes you passed it at a moment on the
short scales when you were probably
going through
the classic mayan bomb and
if one is sensitive to this a weird
kind of psychedelic associationism
begins to spread
through reality and it's no longer seen
to be
just the product of its own past
kazoo history but that it has
relationships to the past and the future
that are not
linear at all but that are linked
through this
strange algorithm
the reason i'm into all this is because
i'm into what's weird
i always have been i mean i've always
loved the bazaar the utrecht
the stuff of the edge and you know i
when i got to psychedelics i thought i'd
hit the
main vein of sprung verse or something
i mean uh if if that's what you
like then this is your answer you see
what the psychedelic is going to do
is it's going to destroy your whole
world
your whole conception of your world and
some people that's tremendously
liberating
they say wonderful at last i'm free of
it other people say
my god now i'm hopelessly mad i have
nothing left to cling to i've really
done it
this time and and so that that's
almost an aesthetic judgment
whether you like watching your world
shredded before your eyes and made into
nonsense if that makes you feel
liberated and secure then you can
sign up for this carnival if that alarms
you
i think best to stick to the tribe and
true
it's not for people of weak psychic
constitution
and what shamanism is about is i mean i
know
someone who says of the mushrooms my
goal with taking mushrooms is
always to be able to stand more
and and they don't mean higher doses
they mean
more of what it reveals and i feel like
that i mean
the mushroom speaks i didn't really
stress this
in my talk but the strange the
confounding
fact about these mushrooms is that they
speak
to you in plain english
and this is a completely
unexpected how can such a thing be i
mean one is done founded
in the presence of this and and yet
uh by being able to have an i
thou relationship to this thing you open
up yourself
to uh what is essentially a magical
dimension a dimension of
allyship uh with this thing
i come to this completely as a
rationalist
i mean i am more scientists
more rationalists than anything else
i am very uncomfortable
with my position in the new age i
hate all that stuff the court's crystal
suppositories and the channeling of
dead egyptians and all this horrible
stuff which goes on
i mean it's just an affront to
the thinking mind but
when i encountered these
psychedelics i said my god
skepticism is the proper path and
and i believe this it's and it's not to
believe
it's to test i said to the mushroom once
why us meaning my brother and me why
us and it said because you don't believe
in anything
you know you're not a believer and so
it's
it's a real thing it's a real mystery
it will not yield to reason
it's a tremendously well-kept secret
i always like my favorite story in the
gospel is the story of
thomas the doubter because remember he
wasn't
present when christ came to the upper
room the first time
after the crucifixion and
and so then thomas came a couple of days
later and the apostles said to him they
said
the master was here he was here
and he said you guys have been smoking
too much of these little brown
cigarettes from
lebanon we saw him crucified he wasn't
here well so then christ came a second
time
and thomas was present and he had said
he said unless i put my hand into the
wound
i will not believe it and so then christ
came the second time and he said
to thomas he said thomas come forward
he said put your hand into the womb
and then he did and my interpretation of
that
gospel story is that alone of
all the apostles it was thomas the
doubter
who touched the resurrection body
because he was the only one who had his
[ __ ] together enough to doubt
and so if you doubt they will actually
let you put your hand into the womb if
you don't
doubt they will give you any kind of
crap and send you happily along your way
so the the best attitude towards these
things
and it gets rid of the phonies
you know the t-locks of this world
but it doesn't get rid of the real stuff
because the real stuff is real
the truth does not require your belief
the truth is real you can beat it on the
ground you can rip it apart you can look
inside
it nobody needs to guard the truth from
inspection
nobody needs to tell you that you know
you can't look
behind the stage and so
my motivation is to try to
number one bring people to the
realization
that the spiritual path
if you want to think of it that way that
is
a real thing and it will carry you
to the real thing
all spiritual disciplines that i know
except for psychedelics
put a great deal of emphasis on putting
the pedal to the metal
push push push you know meditate
make offerings do mantriana do pranayama
do
pusha push push push with psychedelics
suddenly there's a
very deep interest in and where are the
brakes
[Music]
[Applause]
you see you're no longer
pushing once you get to
the psychedelics seeking is an attitude
which ill becomes you
[Music]
you have found it you have
found it now what in the hell are you
going to do with
it yeah and and this is a great dilemma
for for anyone who goes into this i mean
i am
i am as i see myself i'm uh
i'm a preacher in the marketplace
but i know and i'm sure most of you know
that i could walk out of here you could
walk out of here
and you could go as far as your courage
would carry you there is no barrier
there are no more barriers you can go as
far
as your [ __ ] courage will carry you
and at that point you have to ask the
question
you know do i want to be the mad monk of
cold mountain
do i want the villagers to down in the
valley to say
oh yes we see him occasionally up in the
mist
naked flying with the eagles uh
because you can be that person
you know you don't have to go back to
your job as ad exact stock broker or or
whatever it is and so we we
stand on the edge of being able to leave
history
this is what i stand for i stand for
the plants the plants have souls
they carry the morphogenetic field
of thousands of years when you take
psilocybin
it takes you you are participating in
all the trips that it ever induced
in anyone and this is a tremendously
stable
field of experiences when you take
a drug fresh out of the laboratory
it has no soul it has no story it has no
direction
it's a product of the demon artifice
of man and i prefer
to put my hand in the large hand of the
goddess
and make my way into this dimension
under the aegis of the sanctioned
vegetables
that for millennia have always been
there
to fling open the doorways to
vistas of pleasure and delight
that would make you turn up your nose
that the best beverly hills has to offer
believe me
believe me the inner riches are
incomparable
and this is how we recover our dignity
by not being horrors to mammon
and pursuing all of this trash that
they're peddling to us
and insist instead on the maximizing
of human values human emotion
and human community
[Music]
all technology really means in the
mcluhan
sense is the extensions of man
the extensions of man
and so language is a technology
shamanism is a technology psilocybin
is a technology and certainly the
internet
is a technology it's
slowly i think dawning on a number of
people that
if we if we're talking about alisanagen
says consciousness expanding
drugs then the only difference between a
drug and a computer
is that one is slightly too large to
swallow
and our best people are working on that
problem
even as we speak the drugs of the future
will be much more like computers
the computers of the future will be much
more like drugs
well i think of it it's a way of writing
and
i see three main elements
the first is to write about immediate
perceptions
in a fantastic way to think of the
things that you're happening
as being science fiction adventure
perhaps unbelievably strange
but yet they're the real things that
happen to you
[Music]
another point in trans realism
is that you tend not to know how the
work is going to end
such as one of my novels or this film
it's not clear how it's developing the
form is emerging
organically and if you could predict it
it wouldn't be truly alive
the third feature is to use immediate
situations
and immediate characters because those
are the most unpredictable
example we didn't know it
before we came here but lisbon
or lh94 is a resonance of san francisco
it's a city with a suspension bridge
in front of a bay so
trans really we're here in the pudding
so it's like admitting the weirdness of
ordinary existence
it sounds like if the writer can predict
the end of the book so can the reader
the book can't be interesting
is it simply a theory of writing why
couldn't a person live this way
[Music]
you can surely live in a trans real way
is that schizophrenia it could be
[Laughter]
but there can be fun
fun madness where you're
you're permuting the world
[Music]
[Music]
the fish
[Music]
okay here's my makeup
okay here's terence mckenna terence
explain what it is that we're looking at
here this is the monument to the
departure point of the great portuguese
navigators who explored africa
and girdled the world in the 14th
century
because they had the superior technology
of the astrolane
that was what gave them the edge of cool
robert anton wilson robert you want to
make a statement boom hi
hi say hi to dennis hi dennis
well the age of navigation we're going
to navigate
[Applause]
master of chaos me and terence is
the shaman spelled with an x and a
neuromancer
women are fine and boys are divine but
the iguana
is numero uno
right you know these people are not
pretentious they have no powers to grind
but i didn't know what it was that's an
asteroid what does an asteroid do
it allows you to calculate your position
more accurately than any previous
instrument
so they were navigators that was good
[Music]
they say maybe it's just hand oil
tobacco you never know
getting ready for the afternoon's
shooting
this is the easiest job i've ever had
and talk for an hour and then answer
questions for an hour
yeah i don't do i usually just give
scientific lectures
shooting outside today
[Music]
[Music]
i use this principle in the creation of
science fiction
but it sounds like it could be a
philosophy of life as well
that's an interesting point terence we
have a very
active con man's mind
trans realism as a philosophy of life
yes your life is the supreme work of art
which you're creating
as you go along everyone is an artist
their work is their life pay attention
to your immediate perceptions
take them seriously but interpret them
in a fantastic way well as i experience
life it is fantastic so really this is a
call
to realism to admit the presence of the
cosmic giggle
to not suppress it in the name of some
linear notion of
of plot or uh
expectation of how reality should be
[Music]
somehow part of the package of being a
living
thinking being is that
you get a universe inside of you
you know you get a galaxy sized object
inside you that you can access
and there there are the mountains the
rivers
the jungles the dynastic families the
ruins the planets the works of art the
poetry the sciences
the magics of millions upon minions upon
millions of worlds
and this is apparently who we each
are we're a little bit of eternity
sticking into three-dimensional space
and
for some reason occupying time in a
monkey body
but when you turn your eyes then inward
you discover
the birthright the the existential
facts out of which this particular
existence emerged and it's a great
secret a great secret and a great
comfort because it means you know
mystery didn't
die with the fall of arthur or the fall
of atlantis or the fall of anything
mystery is alive in the moment in the
here and now
it just simply lies on the other side of
a barrier of
courage
we are the hands of mother nature there
is no
seam between us and the will of the
planet
we are the technological catalyst
species
that is going to carry dna on this
planet
out into the universe not human dna
all dna and uh long after this planet
has collapsed into its star or been
absorbed an expanding shell of anova
the life that began here all the life
that began
here will be spread throughout the
universe
i'm very my vision is i think biological
not cultural and i even believe you know
that
the mushroom is the cat you can view the
mushroom as the catalyst for this
process
that a hundred thousand years ago there
were only monkeys
and the mushroom and human history
human history is a genetic experiment
by an extraterrestrial resident in the
environment
and i don't know whether the mushroom is
a radio
or the extraterrestrial itself when i
said this morning that if you can if you
understand the dna as a species you will
take control of your
form i always have the notion that
the mushroom has done this and that's
why it touches
matter so very lightly i mean the
mushroom
is a very thinly spread mycelial network
through a field or a meadow somewhere
the the carpet for what we call the
mushroom
is a uh an impertinence to the sexual
process as ralph abraham said one time
it's for sex thrills and sunbathing
and that's all it's for the mushroom is
perfectly able to propagate itself
by vegetatively growing through the soil
but the mushroom if we believe it is an
entity
it lives in its own imagination it has
gotten so rid of a physical form
that all it is is a little bit of white
stuff in the soil
and a raging tree in an unknown
dimension which you can only slice into
by allowing it to load translocate into
your nervous system
and then it continues to give
off its experience of itself
which is an immersion in pure
imagination
you know for it the thought is the fact
of the matter
it's as though the mushroom were made of
pure light
ralph mentioned my my latest
book and i didn't i don't intend to talk
about the book
particularly but i in the book i
quote a uh the only piece of poetry
in the whole thing not written by
me i now see that i seem to have lost it
oh no here it comes up but it relates to
this
on many many levels this question of
illusion and the relationship of the
self
to the real and where the world
falls in that equation and the limits of
knowledge
and all that other good psychedelic
stuff
that needs to be considered
the quote is from pale fire by vladimir
nabokov
and if you don't know this book you
should it is without
doubt one of the funniest books in the
english language
and it takes the form of a very long
poem
and then the commentary upon this poem
the poem is written by a character that
nabakov creates
named john shade and
the part that i want to call to your
attention this evening runs like this
that rare phenomenon the
iridule when beautiful
and strange in a bright sky
above a mountain range one opal
cloudlet in an oval form
reflects the rainbow of a thunderstorm
which in a distant valley has been
staged for we are most
artistically caged
[Music]
now this is a very strange piece of
poetry this is not like
even wallace stevens it is most obscure
in the first place this word the iridual
you won't find this word in any
dictionary
and yet i sensed that this is obviously
the word for this phenomenon
uh i i know what he's talking about
i have seen uh this
uh opal cloudlet in an
oval form which reflects the rainbow of
a thunderstorm in a distant
place we're here we're in the realm
of mirage and nature
as mirage and nature as
mirrored labyrinth in the gray of a
false
dawn the wave of internal imagery faded
away
i rose from where i had been sitting for
hours and stretched
the sky was clear but it was still very
early and stars were still
shining dimly in the west as i stretched
and stood up on the flat stone where i
had been sitting
i noticed that the line of fog seemed to
have grown
darker and now seem to be churning or
rolling in place i watched very
carefully as the rolling line of
darkening mist
split into two parts and each of these
smaller clouds
also divided apart it took only a minute
or so for these changes to be executed
and i was now looking at
four lens shaped clouds of the same size
lying in a row and slightly above the
horizon
only a half mile or so away a wave of
excitement swept
through me followed by a wave of
definite fear
i was glued to the spot unable to move
as if in a dream
as i watched the clouds re-coalesced in
the same way they had divided apart
taking another few minutes the symmetry
of this dividing and rejoining
and the fact that the smaller clouds
were all the same
size length the performance and eerie
air
as if nature herself were suddenly the
tool of some
unseen organizing agency
as the clouds re-coalesced they seemed
to grow even darker and more opaque
as they all became one the clouds seemed
to swirl
inward like a tornado or a water spout
and it flashed into my mind that perhaps
it was a water spout
something i still have never seen i
tried to shout
but no sound came from my
fear-constricted throat
the siren sound was gaining pitch and in
fact
everything seemed to be speeding up the
moving cloud was definitely growing
larger
rapidly moving straight toward the place
where i was
i felt my legs turned to water and sat
down
shaking terribly for the first time
i truly believed in all that had
happened to us
and i knew that the flying concrescence
was now about to take
me its details seemed to solidify as it
approached
then it passed directly overhead in an
altitude of about 200 feet
banked steeply upward and was lost from
sight over the edge of the slope behind
me in the last moment before it was lost
i completely threw open my
senses to it and saw it very clearly
it was a saucer-shaped machine rotating
slowly
with unobtrusive soft blue and orange
lights
as it passed over me i could see
symmetrical indentations on the
underside
it was making the wee sound of science
fiction flying saucers
my emotions were all in a jumble at
first i was terrified
but the moment i knew that whatever was
in the sky was not going to take me
i felt disappointment i was amazed
and i was trying to remember what i had
seen as clearly as possible
was it real in the naive sense in which
that question is
asked of ufos and tables and chairs
no one else saw this thing as far as i
know
i alone was its observer i believe that
had there been other observers
they would have seen essentially what i
have reported
but as for real who can say
i saw this thing go from being a bit of
cloud
to being a rivet-studded aircraft of
some kind
was it more true to itself as cloud or
aircraft
was it a hallucination
and my knees went to water and i just
sat down and
and as it came toward me i could see
i could see orange light a ring of
orange lights on the outside
a ring of soft blue lights on the
underside it was spinning
slowly it was making the hui sound
and it got nearer and nearer and near
till i could actually see the rivets on
the underside of the thing
and then in the last moment before i
lost it behind the edge of the hill
behind me
i saw that it was the
end cap of a 1937
hoover vacuum cleaner that it was in
fact
the same end cap that george adamski
had suspended with a nylon thread
in his garage and photographed with his
brownie camera
to get the three balls you know the
famous
ufo with the three half spheres on the
underside
well that photograph was later totally
debunked it's as
phony as a three-pecker dowel and i
saw it 45 feet in diameter
in the skies above the amazon and
when it was over you know i just howled
because i realized you know this is much
more disturbing
than a ship from zeta reticuli because
this is simultaneously confirmation and
disconfirmation
nobody in their right mind would tell
that story
because the story contains within itself
the seeds of its own disconfirmation
so there is something which plays with
us
actually there's more than you're told
in true illustrations too it's
interesting
in the late summer of 1975 dennis and i
decided that the world we were exploring
required a wider audience so that some
consensus concerning what was going on
could be established to that end we
wrote and published a guide on the
method we had developed to cultivate the
stropharia
at the beginning of that little book i
introduced what we had personally
learned about the world of the mushroom
the mushroom speaks and our opinions
rest
upon what it tells eloquently of itself
in the cool night of the mind
i am old older than a thought in your
species
[Music]
for many worlds scattered through the
shining
disk of the galaxy have conditions which
allow my spores and opportunity for life
the mushroom which you see is
[Music]
these networks may cover acres and may
have far more connections
[Music]
[Music]
across space and
is
is a vast ocean to those hearty life
forms
that have the ability to reproduce
[Applause]
[Music]
until contact is made with a suitable
environment
few such species are minded
only myself and my recently of all new
relatives have achieved the hyper
communication
mode and memory capacity that
makes us leading members of the
community of galactic intelligence
is a secret will not be given lightly to
humanity
but the means should be obvious it is
the occurrence of the psilocybin
in the biosynthetic pathways of my
living body
that opens for me and
material that will eventually carry
humanity and
earth into the galactic mainstream of
the higher civilizations
since it is not easy for you to
recognize other varieties of
intelligence around you
your most advanced series of politics
and society
have advanced only as far as the notion
of collectivism
but beyond the cohesion of the members
of the species into a single social
symbiosis is one of these symbiosis is a
relation of mutual independence and
positive benefits for
both of the species and evolved
symbiotic relationships between
myself and the civilized forms of fire
animals
have been established many times and in
many places
throughout the long ages of my
development
these relationships have been mutually
useful
within my memories the knowledge of
hyperlink
drive shifts and how to build them
i will train this knowledge for a free
ticket
to new worlds around sons less forsaken
galaxies to secure an eternal existence
look what's going on with santa claus
first of all santa claus colors are red
and white
the colors of the amanita muscaria for
sure santa claus
lives at the north pole what does this
mean
it means that santa claus lives at the
axis mundi
where igdrazil the magic world ash of
welch mythology has taken root
santa claus flies this is what shaman do
santa claus is the master of the
reindeer
the animal most associated with the
amanita muscaria
santa claus is aided in his work
by troops of elves and what is
the work of santa claus to build toys
for children
remember the dmt thing saying look at
this
look at this well those were off-duty
elves clearly
and and so so here are all the motifs
and i believe that for children in our
culture
that all the chryster stuff is not what
christmas is about
christmas is about standing in front of
the tree on christmas morning
with the gifts arrayed and the twinkling
lights on
well that tree is the tree that the
amanita muscaria forms its symbiotic
relationship to it's always
spruce or pine that it has a mycorrhizal
relationship
so the number of motifs relating santa
claus to a cult of amino mosquito
there's almost nothing
but relational motifs there and yet if
you suggest this to people they just
back away in horror you know
[Music]
it's something that we always kick
around at these things or i always
bring it up in some form is where do
the hallucinations come from uh
we arrived late last night after a
24-hour
trip from hawaii that was just hell
or as much hell as modern airlines can
legally
inflict the bonus and and
and uh you know got stoned and then we
saw we were laying there
and uh the it always happens when
you know you're cut off from cannabis
for long periods like that
it's ten times as strong and the
hallucinations were
exquisite and you know i've been looking
at hallucinations now
for 30 some years
and and i looked at these last night and
i thought if someone would ask me
what were they like what would i have to
say and
i said indescribable indescribable
and i looked and looked and i could look
to my heart's content
and they were indescribable
so we always come around to this
question
um where do the hallucinations come from
and i suppose
the unconscious reductionists among us
and i don't mean that they're
unconscious i mean that they
unconsciously use reductionism
uh probably assume that
it's some kind of like iteration things
that
bits and pieces of everything you've
ever seen are
rolling in some kind of neurological
kaleidoscope
that can run forever and just produce
this endless
download of drifting imagery
but there's a problem with that because
this stuff is too coherent
it means too much it's too emotionally
charged well we have never
really rallied as a group to try
and locate in our
in our combined opinions the one or
several
sources of these images
and i think that
and i talked a bit about this last year
but i think this is legitimate
perception
of of uh
thoughts places things
times and objects that either have
existed
somewhere in the universe or do exist or
have existed in the minds of beings
somewhere sometime in the universe
in other words that we have to begin to
take seriously
the consequences of generalizations
like quantum connectivity in other words
it's one thing to bask in the light of
the overarching metaphor
which says everything is connected to
everything else
it's quite another thing to say and so
then what are the consequences for me of
this
and the answer seems to me to be
that ins the imagination
the inside of our heads really is
the most vast frontier imaginable
you know you have the hubble telescope
inside of you
and you have inside of you an
informational gathering instrument
that can give you good intelligence
about
things so immeasurably distant from this
point that to stated in numbers and
units is meaningless
it's just elsewhere the elsewhere of the
absolute infinity
of the of the plenum of imagination
in which apparently beings rise and fall
like plankton
in the sea
i'm not an abuser
it takes me a long time to assimilate
each experience
and i feel you know i never have lost my
respect for it i mean i really feel
dread
is one of the emotions that i always
feel as i approach it because i have no
faith
that my sails won't be ripped this time
i always make the metaphor you know it's
like sailing out onto a dark ocean in
your little skiff
and you know you may view the moon
rising
serenely over the calm black water or
something the size of a freight train
may roar
right through your scene and leave you
clutching at an oar
and i don't know astrology is maybe
helpful in figuring out when to go and
when not to go but
there needs to be a way to figure out
when to go
and when not to go now your question
about the dialogue
i i mean this very literally uh
it speaks to you you speak to it it says
things i don't know how many of you have
read my the book that my brother and i
wrote under
pseudonyms called psilocybin the magic
mushroom grower's guide
but in the introduction there there's a
wrap which is all about
uh i am old 50 times older than thought
in your species and i came from the
stars
well that's verbatim you know i just was
writing it furiously
and sometimes it's it's very human i
mean my approach to it is acidic
i rave at it it raves at me we argue
about what it's going to cough up
and what it isn't and i say well look
you know
i'm the grower you can't hold back on me
and it says well but if i showed you the
flying saucer for five minutes you would
figure out how it works
and i said oh
and my plea to scientists administrators
and politicians who may be listening to
my voice
is to look again at psilocybin
to not uh lump it with the other
psychedelics to realize
that it is a phenomenon unto itself and
it has an enormous potential
for transforming mankind not simply
transforming the people who take it
but it is like an art movement or a
mathematical understanding or a
scientific breakthrough it holds the
possibility
of transforming the entire society
simply by virtue of
the information that is coming through
this is a source of gnosis and the voice
of gnosis
has been silenced in the western mind
for at least a thousand years
say no this is a little too vincent
price
how about
[Music]
i've told the story about
how in the amazon when all this stuff
was breaking loose
i went through this period where
very calmly and deeply and without
having any need to tell anyone
i thought i came to the opinion
that i was like in life
and it was this very low key thing it
was all about
appropriate behavior this was the
cognitive hallucination that i was
having it was
about appropriate behavior and i had
this idea there's an appropriate way
to do everything and if you
do it the appropriate way no energy
will be lost and so you become like
super conducting you become like some
kind of super
tai chi character where you just do
things
so nifty that there's no problem whether
it's plucking a flower or
moving a boulder and i was told when you
think sit on the ground
this was there were all these teachings
and they were very simple
they were things like sit on the ground
stupid
and uh you know use your
fingers that was a big teaching use your
fingers so one of the things i was into
was how you wash the pot we had one pot
it was this little enamel pot
and we would bake it over a fire and we
baked beans and we baked rice and all
these terrible things
that would get scum on the bottom and so
it was a big deal about drawing lots for
who washed the pot
well i discovered in my enlightened
state
that we had been doing it all wrong
and that if you would go down to the
water with the pot
and and take sand and pat it
very very lightly in the bottom
and then say please
but then all you had to do was pour
water into the pot
and swish it around and empty it like
that and then when you looked in
it would be like drano you know it would
just be
blinding white and i did this
several times and i thought how
appropriate
a miracle this is this is a real miracle
i mean this is just
simple stuff it's totally here and now
it's absolutely taoist it's completely
you know on and on
uh so then i had a critic
in our crowd and so i thought
that i would enlighten the critic
by a wordless demonstration
of my obvious command of the
howling dao so
i invited the critic to accompany me to
the river
and uh and i said and now notice that i
pick up the sand
i pat it into the bottom i'm not
agitating it i look into the sky and i
say
please and then i put water in it
and i swish it around
i said is something supposed to happen
[Music]
and i look and the crud adhere
[Music]
and then this person says you know i
pity you
[Music]
and i would pity you more but you alarm
[Laughter]
me
[Music]
my life is fairly science fictiony
and carries over at this
question which i grapple with all the
time which is who do you work for
what is going on here do you understand
what you're doing
and if you don't who does and why did
they
set you marching because i can tell
what's happening here we're trying to
tinker with something
it's a groping in the dark for a button
we're trying to make something happen by
saying
words by setting examples by empowering
people
to do certain things this is the
mushrooms
program not mine i mean left to myself
i would probably be a hermit and i'm
much too cynical
for crusades but the mushroom isn't
the mushroom is a gung-ho kind of guy
and you know has this whole vision of
man and fungus hand in hand to the stars
and i just say you know you just meet
the damnedest people out in the fields
you know
and this is one of them
and uh it's just a matter of shopping
around
you know and finding out what actually
sets your knees knocking what actually
makes
tears of joy run down your face
spontaneously what actually can make you
groggle and plead for mercy and
it is this force this
real invocation of real spirit
it is a dark night of the soul it is an
ecstasy
apotheosis uh uh
apple catastrosis it even happens
outside of
greek it is pure
challenge meth and overcome pure
self authentication and in a world
where we are just buffeted
used set against one another
misled misconstrued lied to
and controlled nevertheless
you can just push between the tents of
carnival row
and walk out into the woods and there
you
find the spiritual life waiting
there you find the lymphatic waters of
the dao
that were always there and
it's a matter of courage
nature loves courage nature
is an infinitude of doorways opening
into
authentic being calling to us
with the voice of our ancestors the
spirits of the planet
the time travelers that rove the
centuries ahead of us
and who knows what else the whole
fact of being is a palpable ongoing
continuous miracle and we know this
we feel it you know i'm saying this
because i'm glib but any we all know
it that's how i'm able to say it you
know
it is elicited from the group mind if it
weren't in you
i would be incomprehensible so we
form then and understand it
and then we each are strengthened in the
private trials of
our souls when we go to meet these
things when we try to hammer out
a relationship to the ally when we try
to
hammer out a relationship to the
denizens of our own
unconscious this is life authentically
[Music]
lived
there is building in global society an
increasingly intense expectation of the
intervention into human history by ufos
it is very similar in tone to the
build-up of messianic expectation
in the hellenistic world in the several
centuries preceding the birth of christ
the leaders of roman society may have
been caught off guard by the appearance
of christ
but they had no one to blame but
themselves since
millions of people in the ancient world
were expectantly awaiting
some kind of messiah so today
science and government poo poo the idea
of world contact with the ufos
while the contact cults grow ever larger
and more insistent
that contact is about to occur
imagine therefore what you may never
have seriously imagined before
imagine what would happen if the ufos
were to appear
imagine a spaceship of the close
encounters of the third
kind variety suddenly appearing in orbit
around the earth
television and mass media would carry
its image to every man woman and child
on the planet governments would be
paralyzed
science would be helpless to explain
where it came from
or how it got here millenarian hysteria
would break out everywhere
the ufo would be hailed as savior and
denounced as antichrist
the end of the world would appear
imminent and
all this would occur before the contact
was more than a visual image
then the ufo would begin its revelation
vast displays of beneficent power can be
expected
perhaps it would mysteriously neutralize
all weapons of mass destruction
or it might use some sort of ray to cure
all terrestrial cancer
whatever it does one may be sure that
its actions
will be impressive its actions will
convert
millions to the ufo religion in a space
of
ours indeed its actions will be
specifically designed to overwhelm us
with the reality of its
power and presence that will close
the first stage of the revelation
the second stage will be the teachings
telepathically imparted the specifics of
the teachings cannot be anticipated
but they will urge love voluntary
simplicity
concern for one another renunciation of
war
perhaps renunciation of the destructive
application of science
whatever the teachings the ufo will
promise immense reward to those who
follow them
and dire consequences for those who do
not
and the teachings will be delivered in
so poetically perfect a way
so rich in understanding and appealing
nuances
that no one will doubt their origin in a
being
wise and good and immensely superior to
ourselves
the delivery of the teachings will set
the stage for the third
and last and most shocking phase of the
revelation
the departure the saucer promising
vaguely to return
will simply disappear
the entire process could take less than
a month
if this seems a short time recall that
the entire public career of christ
lasted only three years christ's career
occurred in a world where information
could move no
faster than a horse's gallop yet three
years in one small part of the world was
all that was necessary to launch a world
religion that was vital
for 1500 years in a world of electronic
communication the
impact of the saucers arrival miracles
teaching and departure would be
incalculable
even if it all occurred within a month
the saucer would leave in its wake as
science utterly unable to provide
any answers to the important questions
concerning what had gone on
the vast majority of people would be
fanatical converts to the teachings of
the saucer
and any institution in opposition to
those teachings could expect to be swept
away
almost overnight the departure of the
ufo would create a sense of abandonment
the agony of which could be expected to
echo in the human
psyche for centuries the only panacea
would be the religion of the saucer
the religion left behind science would
be discredited and soon abandoned
in favor of a thousand or more years of
exegesis
of the sausarian message is it not a
familiar pattern in the light of our
discussion of christ and rome
what will never be said in the wake of
such an event
and so must be said now while there is
still
time for all of the above could occur
and yet
still be deception a benign deception
designed to save us from our advanced
science and
infantile ethics but a deception
nevertheless
the saucer no matter how alien it
appears
no matter how advanced its
demonstrations of power
is not a vehicle from some other star
system
it is the over soul of humanity up to
its oldest trick
if one knows this one can live
through the revelation and the
destruction of our scientific world
and yet evade the immense power of this
most
powerful of all transference phenomenon
and thereby maintain the integrity of
one's own
soul and spirit remember i
am not a debunker of flying saucers or a
defender of science
i am a contact d and this book
is the painstakingly told story of my
own involvement with the ufos
i am one of those valet has pinpointed
as being a carrier of ideas that pave
the way for the scenario i have just
described
yet from it all i have learned that
there is no
religious revelation more satisfying
than the hard-won
fruits of simple understanding
[Music]
because you know ultimately what you're
thrown back on
is that you are a monkey it's not it's
nothing to be ashamed of but on the
other hand it's nothing to
write out of the equation either you're
a monkey for god's sake
and yet you're asking to understand
the nature of reality what would you
think of a squirrel
that ran around with that as a goal
i mean you would just think you know
what why don't you just bury
nuts make noise in the trees
well so now we have particle physicists
and quantum physicists and
and but even they admit
that matter has now become so wacky
that the grand enterprise of the
conquest of reality through
reason has rea has revealed that
reason has no place
in the domain of reality the reality
itself
is not reasonable rupert was just
describing to me
a conference he was at with dennett the
guy who wrote consciousness
explained you probably all know that
book
and it should have been called
consciousness explained away
but anyway was saying
you know i want to get rid of magical
matter in the brain i just believe the
brain is this and that nothing i want to
get rid of magical matter
well there was a quantum physicist there
stefan glashau of harvard and he said
well i've got
news for you john quantum physics has
turned
matter into magical material
so now they're the whole program of
saving
reason has to be abandoned the
prosecution of the understanding of
nature has pushed us to the point where
we see that
that matter itself exceeds rational
apprehension what does that mean giving
up codifying stuff i mean
it gives up the idea it means giving up
the idea of closure
that there's not no conclusions no
conclusions
i was just at a conference where i met
all these people from ecuador and there
was an
anthropologist there some of you may
know this guy sparrow miller
and he lives with the warranty in
ecuador and he told me he said the
amazing thing about the warranty
is that they don't think anything
makes sense that's their official
explanation of the universe is that
nothing
makes sense and so they are completely
at home
with that consequently their
contribution to epistemology has been
vanishingly small
on the other hand they have a very good
time and they're quite
comfortable with their wives children
otherwise they don't
understand anything why should we
understand
look at us we wear penis sheaths and
paint ourselves blue
you're asking us
it's not at all clear that we're mapping
a generalizable reality
it may be that it's just so huge in
there that
never do we pass through the same uh
matrix
twice well that
means you can give up on closure
you can give up on any on any theory
that will ever
give you uh very much of a more than
provisional handle
on what's going on and i think this is
probably a good to
a good step to take to open ourselves to
the freedom
that lies beyond culture culture is a
kind of prison
and the only way that we know to get
beyond it
is to dissolve its boundaries now you
can do that with psychedelics
and then you really explore the baseline
of being
or you can dissolve it with travel but
then
you dissolve your own cultural
programming only to discover you've
fitted yourself
into somebody else's cultural
programming and this
well uh you know definitely educational
is like a psychedelic drug i'm not that
fond of
i do a lot of traveling but it's not the
same thing
as replacing space and time with some
kind of alternative
that comes from uh you know doing the
hard work
on five brains and silent
and really what you see i think is
the morphogenetic field the invisible
world
that holds everything together the knit
of it all not the knit of matter and
light
but the mint of kazoo history of
intentionality
caring hope of dream of thought
and and that all is there
but it's been hidden from us for
centuries
because of the exorcism of the spirit
that took place in order to allow
science
to do business and that
you know momentous and ill-considered
choice
then has made us the inheritors
of a tradition of
of existential emptiness really
but that has impelled us to go back to
the jungles
and to recover this thing it's all of
the peace
you see i mean these people in the
amazon and whatnot
we're keeping this cultural flame
burning
but these cultures are now all dead
they are either dead or in a state of
advanced
uh suspended animation
it's a very strange enterprise and it's
hard to put it across
because the thing is it's real you know
and we're in the effort you know in the
habit of thinking
that the mind can move unobstructed from
one edge of the universe to the other
that there are no secrets but actually
there are
secrets at least these
are secrets and hard to tell
i mean i i tell them and you hear them
and we seem to have been allowed a
cosmic dispensation
but why that is it's very hard for me to
understand i would have thought that
this would have been headline
news 20 000 years ago right up until the
present
instead you know it's very tentative
apparently this is very threatening
to us we are not as eager to sail over
the age
collectively as we think we are so then
it becomes
the function of the shaman the gadfly
the go-between to carry information
back and forth between these worlds
i'm convinced that if there were no
shamanic
pipeline there would be no human life
as we know it on this planet i mean that
could be climaxed animal life
there was no need for this higher-order
linguistic
style of self-reflection to come into
being
it's that something is closet
something is working itself out in
us we are the cells of a much larger
body and like the cells of our
own body it's very hard for us to
glimpse the whole pattern
behold what is happening and yet we can
sense that there is a purpose
and there is a pattern well the way you
connect
the pattern with the lower level is
by dissolving the boundaries of the ego
and the self
into this larger thing and then it's
found to be there
reflective on many levels it's not it
doesn't require a mechanism
everything is obvious if things don't
appear
simple to us i think it's because we
haven't thought about it
well so that's sort of a survey of some
of this stuff
thank you very much
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
mom
[Music]
so
[Music]
we are closing distance with the first
moments of true human civilization
you know when people actually do treat
each other with respect when there
actually
is a place made for the celebration of
human differences
when we actually do feel the suffering
of the people around us and respond to
that
so without psychedelics and the models
that they
make possible hope is i think a
very very fragile thing and that's why
i take the position that i do because i
think
that we are on the brink of the
adventure for which
we left the trees and left
the african plain but it's
not a sure thing it rests in our hands
as it always has i mean remember that
in the last million years nine times
the ice has moved south from the poles
miles high pushing before it
our ancestors people wrapped in skin
naked as j birds marginal as can be
no antibiotics no global weather
forecasting no
nothing and they didn't drop the ball
they survived they took care of their
children and their
elderly they passed the skills and the
technologies and the insights and the
songs
down the long stream of time can we do
any less we who have in our hands
the power to shape the planet for good
or evil we who can communicate with each
other
globally in a moment it would be a
pretty sad
commentary on the notion of cultural
progress
and intelligence if they could keep the
faith
and we can't so it all went
for this it will all be made
clear in the lifetime of most of us
and so i just want to uh sort of close
on that note
invite you to keep the faith invite you
to explore the edges
and to make of yourself a a vessel
a conduit for the world transforming
logos that is trying to speak to all of
us
to create a sane and viable
and celebratory world for our children
and their children thank you very much
[Applause]
we wish to express our grateful
appreciation to the many friends who
aided this project
in south america we were assisted by
michael lasky
erica meatfeld sarah hartley the ritoto
people of la cherrera
and the mission of la charrera were most
hospitable the former providing
invaluable access
to local psychoactive parents
thank the mushroom terence is his own
voice
dennis plays himself many effects were
recorded on location
throughout the world thank you terence
thank the book for being a vehicle thank
the machinery
thank the weather thank the ancestors
thank the listeners thank you lucky
stars
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
don't you know what i used to know
[Music]
[Music]
highly respectable
[Music]
understood
[Music]
up
stepped into a highly sensational
society you might have a sensational
shoes i sing highly sensational songs
along with highly sensational
oh
[Music]
[Music]
understood
it can only be good
we've now reached the 22nd of march 1971
and i was just i couldn't
i couldn't talk to anybody i was uh
in a in a very very very very
strange place i mean things went on
well just as an example because there
wasn't much
of this 3d stuff that you could you
could
wrap your mind around but everything was
teaching
me everything had a message
for me and i would go out into the
jungle
and i would uh i would raise my arms
above my head and i would call
the butterflies into me out of the
jungle
and they would come first in by
dozens and then by hundreds and i would
stand there
and here's how the thought progression
would go
i would i would call the butterflies in
and then i would uh
it would move me to tears
so there i am standing covered with
butterflies
tears of joy streaming down my face
and streaming down my face and streaming
down my face
and finally i begin thinking
so now what and
then i think ah the people back at the
camp who doubt me
those bastards wait till they see this
so then i would go to the camp and i
would be smiling the tiny smile that
only buddhas can manage
and i would invite them into the jungle
to see
something unannounced and so they would
say well i don't know you just
all right we'll go so then we would go
into the jungle and i would raise my
hands above my head
and i would call the butterflies in and
none
would come
and these people would just say oh god
it's just it's getting worse and worse
and worse your brother is nuts
you have delusions of grand this is
pathetic
i mean this is a mind and wreckage
this is the green hell this is the thing
we
feared the most you know and
so eventually and any of you who are
self-diagnosed as schizophrenic will
agree with me on this
i'm sure the key to surviving
schizophrenia
in one piece and avoiding massive
intervention by the mental health care
authorities is shut up
shut up about it do not talk about it
all the you of course you can raise the
dead and heal the sick and divine
distant event but just shut up about it
or you're not going to make it through
well
eventually everybody else sort of
re-negotiated themselves back to some
kind of reality
my brother flew back to the states and i
was
in a sense left in the amazon to
mull all this
[Music]
[Music]
the mushroom once said to me this is
what it's like
when a species prepares to depart for
the stars
not to worry
well they've been speaking to you for a
while
[Laughter]
in my highest states i have had the
insight which i will convey to you
without saying it's true
that this is the most limited
form of existence you will ever know
you can't be deader than this
this is the bottom
line and and
so the good news is it's it's only
up from here
any similarity to persons living or dead
is purely coincidental
then would you be convinced well
look at this